some big guys sitting over there waiting
for you you said you don't know who he
is
you ukrainian boxer victor drago appear
today in Philadelphia
bringing back Ivan Drago and his son
Victor in that history that animosity it
just made it more intense
this is Creed vers Drago this is the
fight the whole world wants to see
unless he's afraid of history repeat
itself
Rocky's past has caught up to him
because the darkest moment in Rocky's
life is when Apollo Creed's substituted
for him it's a fight Drago and he died
and so now the donnas Creed feels like
he should avenge his father ain't got a
choice that's the same thing your father
said and he died right here in my hands
Ivan Drago is the iconic character for
destroying one of our other iconic air
does Apollo Creed so it was really cool
to revive him in a way that felt fresh
and new because of you I lose everything
Yvan was a Olympic champion he was a
hero of the Soviet Union but 33 years
ago he lost a fight with the Jew Rocky
Balboa so now he's trying to turn his
life around
using his son as the vehicle for him to
come back onto the world stage perhaps
because of the history it's easy to make
this match up so this is his big chance
and it's not about treats about him and
his father having break you to money you
know the stakes it's a loaded situation
these dudes killed my pops I can't let
that slide the ciock laid out in a new
generation with a new
I go in the new create it was fantastic
this is our chance to rewrite history
you